This
is the Cal N.E.H. American English dialect recordings collection.
Tape number fifty one so
be
English big interviews made in the summer of one nine hundred seventy four in
Asheville North Carolina by
Ronald butters of Duke
University the research was supported by the
National Endowment for the Humanities Grant
and by the Department of English at Duke University. The first
speaker is a white female aged thirty seven at
the time of the
interview
named on
May tenth one thousand seventy four. The speaker
is unusual because she is the
only one thing now. Under the
age of sixty where this interview is a part
of this project. She also is.
From the rural community
south
Asheville Barney. You're pulling than I
was twelve bar. You
know telling a story
straight and have one little never bought a hit and you have that stuff back in
the back of the ball and go. OK.
Oh boy oh boy.
Yes. So
you
go about
twenty three.
And there's no what if I look
at
coerced and first time.
And
they
don't change.
Year.
And
loan to.
Do
you got a
C. and then Oh yeah.
So we're out here.
I don't know.
Right there.
There's a battery about a battery.
Far easier
to
explain that so we are next to Newport.
And it's back in your home.
And I've already gone to Canada.
Have been all there on the drive a car
a big black
bear and I went over to D.D..
That lives over with me to find out how do you
know.
Any head. Right.
And I got up there and man says which one do you want.
I got to one had the most black and black
and was black because of the
type and. I
wanted to put the black back in
her life. Now the first thing we
got have to have brought her home
from her euro and face with head
head
and.
How you talk about the.
Draft pick up truck to drive the dragon version.